字幕志愿者 李宗盛
今集跟大家說了OBV
OBV指標很簡單
其實是依照行程的漲跌
去累計市場上每天的成交量
實際上的計算方式
你們可以看到有三條
但在實戰方面我們是怎樣形容的呢?
我們同樣道理
用幾個股票去看一看
新股,老大師,3601
你見到,實際上的漲跌很簡單
OBV 向下走代表是體弱的
如果向上走,就要看好
但我們也要看趨勢,究竟是甚麼趨勢呢?
譬如它會升得急,還是跌得急
都是反映著利好和另淡的
有時價錢正常升的時候,應該是OBV向上升
但如果OBV是同樣東西的價格升,但OBV下跌
其實代表那隻股票有機會向下走
這就能夠成正比
但大家可以看到,我當作是這裡
打橫的obv可能是沒有動的
但整個curve一直向下走的價錢這代表什麼呢?我們看到旁邊有負數和正數由負數變成正數
大家看到正數
代表買盤很積極
由負變成正數
其實是買進的信號
另外我們看看圖
恆生指數
恆生指數,大家看到反反覆覆,又升又跌
恆生指數由10月20日開始,大家看到OBV一直向上升
這個數字,其實旁邊一直向上升
這個情況是特別升得很高
即是你見到趨勢本來很橫行,頂得住OBV沒什麼跌
甚至OBV還向上升,反映出市場上的買班很積極
尤其是越升得急代表越積極
最後拿回方達
之前OBV一直向上升,一直跟著市場走
OBV跌就跌,價格也一樣跟著跌
如此類推,其實是很像樣的,因為這個 OBV 實際上跟現金流和買賣盤的大方向是成正比的
所以大家要留意一件事,如果 OBV 由一個大的數字慢慢收窄到一個小的數字
甚至你看到拉一個比例去到之前的低位的時候
好的話可能是這些回調都趁低吸納的時候
不好的話會跌穿上一次OBB指標
其實就代表快要跌穿
甚至跌穿零變成負數
是一個做空的時間來的
今集就講到這裡了